okay next game I got the same opponent
and woody pop the 101 basically lost
some time last last game by spending so
much time early on yeah symmetrical
English and he's playing a 3 this is
somewhat done he has a solid line for
white
monitoring this with the counter
fianchetto here
like usually I'm continues IAM with pure
Queen d7 covering yeah okay you can do
this and temporarily display some this
night here but it usually will get into
play later on dat six or something okay
just um just night of six sometimes it's
an idea to play night age 62 f five in
this kind of positions to keep the
diagonal open
yeah not quite sure what is what is plan
is in regards to the center maybe maybe
play with e4 at some point d for looks
looks weird to me because C for that
would be very weak so maybe he form I
want to of course some reposition this
night it's got just a terrible position
here and what about d5 canopy d5 even
opening it and then play the night to d6
maybe I need to be aware of 95 at some
point if I have to see 66 is a week
square but still this is it's looking
looks like an active possibility yeah
okay this should be just just trying for
black you might go for c4 with this
night but still hard to believe that
black should be worse here I can also
play for see for myself and yeah but
it's just weakens b5 doesn't it
he's playing a much quicker now
my dears to get some play against them
against b5 pawn rook d5 to get this
night away and give this some young but
damn I was just thinking um king of 6cm
covering your seven now be five is to
staying
uh-huh
he wants to defend with rook every check
here
yeah okay I'm already really am probably
short on time some need to speed up him
yeah this was what I had in mind the
rockin tonight now somehow dominate this
piece it doesn't have have a square and
e2 is hanging was check also oh this is
what we hear it's got rook easy but i
can I can just I can just push this pawn
time warning
I got the I really got the feeling that
I can just play this one very simple
rookie three Roxy seven and the night is
trapped I could have done this before I
think even stranger should have seen
this much much earlier before I even
known got got the King moving
yeah i saw the general idea of the night
i'm not having too many squares but
somehow i didn't follow this thought to
the end now the pawn is just just
promoting I think Brooke see one check
white resides no yeah this went downhill
really quickly funny funny little
details and now i should play rook see
one check first he's got a rook takes f7
now I did see this at all which leads to
completely drawn endgame but this is
some yeah this is just winning I can
play king of eight now i will ever
looked Roxy seven Roxy seven idea i only
saw it here so I could have I could have
gone gone this gun play this all the
time rook rook c7 now o king of eight
both both win yeah funny yeah I'm pretty
pretty decent one I guess yeah next one